hallöchen meine lieben Freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge
Minecraft freeze heute am 4 Dezember ich
habe mir gedacht Luca heute ist der 4
dezember von daher kommt heute natürlich
eine Folge Minecraft freeze ich bin
allerdings alleine heute und zwar haben
wir das jetzt eigentlich so gemacht dass
dieser Server dass ich meine freeze Welt
hier bereit Stelle dass wir da so ein
paar mehr Youtuber mit drin haben dass
da jeder mal so mehr oder weniger drin
aufnehmen kann allerdings habe ich mir
gedacht nur weil wir das ganze so
gemacht haben heißt es ja nicht
unbedingt dass ich immer einen mit dabei
haben muss deswegen dachte ich mir so
back root nein Spaß gehe ich mal
einfach jetzt hier so alleine in diese
Welt und quatsche so so ein bisschen
aber nee das war gar nicht meine
Holzkohle aber wir wollen ja auch
eigentlich so miteinander umgehen dass
man immer wer hat mir D Block geklaut
das kann auch nicht sein wer mir den
Block geklaut irgendwer ist da
hingegangen hat mir ein Block geklaut oh
Mann wie freck ist das denn ich habe ja
in der letzten Folge schon gesagt dass
wir das ganze jetzt zum down also nicht
zum Download freigegeben haben aber es
sind jetzt auch andere Youtuber mit
dabei und wir haben gedacht dass wir
jetzt einfach hier zusammen in das ganze
bisschen aufnehmen jeder baut h nach der
Zeit ich schaue hier schon immer so ein
bisschen falls euch fragt warum ich hier
rumlaufe ob sich hier schon irgendwas
verändert ist weil es haben bisher schon
zwei Leute glaube ich aufgenommen also
max hat schon aufgenommen justin hat
schon aufgenommen kedos und KEV meine
ich
das einzige was ich bisher sehe ist
da ein Baum und da sowas aber jetzt ich
weiß nicht ob da hinten noch irgendwas
war was ist das hier denn wieso ist das
hier denn abgerissen was soll das wieso
wird denn das hier gegrieved Alter das
verstehe ich echt nicht eigentlich
wollten wir das so machen dass es nicht
gegrievt wird aber mir fällt gerade auf
lol hallo Kos
Tag was für ein Zufall einfach wir haben
uns nicht
abgesprochen ich stehe im
Regen W haben uns nicht abgesprochen
dass wir hier zusammen aufnehmen sondern
einfach nur ich habe jetzt einfach drauf
los aufgenommen und kedos wohl
auch oh m wie witzig da sehen wir uns
jetzt einfach hier das ja interessant na
ja das ist auf jeden Fall so das genau
das was Minecraft freeze darstellen soll
und zwar dass man einfach so zusammen
aufnehmen kann wenn man will eigentlich
wollte ich jetzt alleine aufnehmen aber
jetzt trotzdem noch ein auf dem Server
gegangen mal schauen an was der kedos
gleich Arbeiten wird oh das war
natürlich bisschen doof ich wollte
nämlich ich habe mir gerade gedacht dass
ich jetzt ist natürlich blöd mit dem
Regen ich ma den mal ganz kurz aus hier
einfach
damit damit die
Atmosphäre Bächer ist jedenfalls war
hier irgendwer am Werk meine Freunde ich
weiß nicht wer aber es war jemand am
Werk ich wollte hier so ein so ein
kleinen entweder so ein so ein iklu
hinbauen oder ey komm ich ma ein iklu
oder ich kann ja eigentlich habe 21
Schnee ich glaube ich mache mir noch ein
paar Schaufeln obwohl ich glaube ich
brauch gar nicht so viel Schaufel na
doch ich ma mir trotzdem mal
sicherheitalber noch eine eisenschaufel
dafür brauche ich aber erstmal hier
Dings dann werde ich einfach mal ein
bisschen Schnee holen und versuchen so
ein Iku zu machen und werde dabei
natürlich wieder auf ein paar Fragen
eingehen die mir als erstes zugesendet
wurde von ich habe noch fast gar nicht
in die facecam geschaut sigo HD schreibt
ccrafter
#fagluka ich habe am Anfang ja immer
gesagt ja #fagla ist der # wenn ihr
Fragen an mich habt fürs Projekt und so
und der war auch schon oft in den Trends
und so und das danke ich euch natürlich
das natürlich sehr sehr fresh
aber die Sache ist ach cool das kann ich
auch mitnehmen die Sache ist halt dass
dieses wieso kommen denn da immer zwei
Schneebälle raus guck mal jetzt habe ich
da vier geh ich dahin jetzt habe ich
sechs e chillig da kommen echt mal zwei
raus die Sache ist halt einfach ist das
Schnee oder Erde oh m das ist Erde wir
haben jetzt halt gedacht dass wir für
die es Projekt Minecraft freeze nimmt
jeder wenn er Fragen stellt bei Twitter
wenn er Fragen braucht irgendwie wenn er
sagt okay ich beantworte paar Fragen
nimmt jeder einfach den has#fze jetzt
immer also wenn ihr Fragen und habt #fze
und da drunter einfach bei Twitter
stellen und nicht mehr an # fragt Luca
das könnt ihr auch noch machen da schaue
ich auch noch rein am besten immer mich
verlinken concrafter und dann
noch dann noch #fes und dann noch den
#fagla dann sehe ich das auf jeden Fall
ähm aber ich nehme einfach jetzt hier
den Schnee mit alter hier kommt einfach
viel mehr raus das ist viel besser
jedenfalls wenn ihr Fragen habt könnt
ihr die da ganz easy peasy einfach
hinsenden und ich habe da wir haben uns
halt gedacht wenn jeder diesen Hashtag
benutzt okay meine Schaufel ist kaputt
wenn jeder diesen Hashtag alter das ist
ja hier alles
vollgkanoneis sch der ganz Inventar voll
wir haben uns gedacht wenn jeder einfach
diesen Hashtag benutzt dann ist es
eventuell so dass dieser Hashtag nachher
einfach immer in den Trends ist also das
ist unsere unsere utopievorstellung sage
ich jetzt einfach mal so das ist die
Vorstellung wo wir denk das wäre
natürlich perfekt wenn das immer
irgendwie in den Trends wäre dass man
das Projekt echt cool machen könnte
dadurch und was auch extrem witzig ist
ist einfach ähm dass dann quasi wenn die
eine Person denkt okay ich möchte gerade
nachts aufnehmen irgendwann um 4 Uhr und
denkt sich dann aber h keiner schickt
mir irgendwelche Themen jetzt weil
keiner mehr online ist um die Uhrzeit
dann kann man halt einfach sagen okay
gut unter dem has#agfeze schaue ich dann
und bei dem #agfeze ist es halt so dass
da einfach immer dann Sachen sind weil
jeder diesen Hashtag dann benutzt also
ich hoffe ihr versteht da so ein
bisschen was ich meine also deswegen
einfach Fragen unter #fe und jetzt
kommen wir zur Frage und zwar fragt sig
HD bist du in Weihnachten oft Schlitten
gefahren und war oder warst du lieber so
der heiße schokotrank und daheim bleibt
Typ mein Inventar ist einfach schon
wieder voll aber um auf die Frage
zurückzukommen ich fahre schon ach so
ich hatte gerade Hunger ich fahre schon
gerne Ski und Schlitten die Sache ist
halt dazu habe ich auch eine kleine
Story am Start und zwar bin ich damals
mein Vater und so ist mein Vater Ski
gefahren
mit seinem Schlitten und ich halt mit
meinem und dann sind wir halt so ein
Berg runtergefahren und dann habe ich
irgendwann nachdem wir da nachdem wir da
irgendwie schon so z D Stunden am am
Schlittenfahren waren immer hochgelaufen
dann wieder runtergefahren und so weiter
und so fort haben wir dann einfach mal
so ein Rennen gemacht und da habe ich
ihn tatsächlich überholt ich weiß nicht
ob ich mich extra hat überholen lassen
oder nicht aber es war auf jeden Fall
richtig witzig und da habe ich mich
sogar richtig cool gefühlt und habe
gesagt irgendwann werde ich
schlittenweltmeister und so aber ich bin
dann ich bin eigentlich beide Arten also
ich wenn ich jetzt zur Zeit fahre ich
natürlich lieber Ski anstatt Schlitten
aber wenn ich skifahre denkt man
natürlich schon boah gleich bist unten
in der Hütte und hast kaiserschmaren vor
dir mit dem Kakao oder Glühwein oder so
das denke ich mir D natürlich schon aber
Skifahren ist an sich auch schon richtig
geil also ich mag beides ich bin D so
ein breit aufgestellter Typ es ist auch
erlaubt dass man einfach so auf dem
Server nebenbei auf drauf geht wenn man
einfach gar nicht so aufnimmt das ist
schon ganz chillig aber das sind so
Sachen die müssen wir auch noch mal
durchsprechen in der Konfi es soll
wirklich nicht so viele Regeln geben das
soll ein ganz chilliges Projekt sein und
ach hier die Seide habe ich ja zur Wolle
gemacht sonst hätte ich mir jetzt ein
Bogen gemacht nächste Frage von da sem
nein wie findest du Häuser wo überall
drumrum oder drauf Weihnachtsdeko ist
frohe Weihnachten schon mal frohe
Weihnachten schon mal zurück ich weiß
nicht ob man sich das jetzt schon
wünscht aber ich halte nicht so viel von
diesen Häusern und zwar ich finde
Weihnachtsdeko muss vom Herzen sein und
da kann man nicht einfach einin ganzes
Haus mit voll kleistern das mag ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht so das blöde ist
halt dieses Texture Pack macht zwar Gras
einfach so zu Schnee also das ist kein
Schnee sondern das ist einfach die
Grastextur in diesem Texture Pack aber
das blöde ist einfach dieses ganze Gras
hätte am besten auch weiß g sein gemusst
weil jetzt ist das so kom komch grün und
jetzt ihr seht ja schon wenn ich mich
jetzt einfach mal umdrehe das sieht
extrem komisch aus wenn hier dieses
komische Zeugs ist conis Mama s
chrispomkugel junge K na ja jedenfalls
sowas wä dann halt eine Arbeit die man
ganz kurz offscreen machen würde
allerdings bin ich noch ein bisschen
gegen dieser offscreen Sache weil man
dann rein theoretisch halt auch einfach
cheaten könnte natürlich hat H niemand
ah okay das geht doch nicht es hat ja
niemand OP auf diesem Server außer ich
und sturmwaffel weil wir das ganze
machen aber ich würde eh nichts
offscreen machen weil ich das nicht so
der Fan von bin aber wir müssen einfach
mal schauen wie wir das noch machen mit
den Regeln aber um auf die Frage zurückz
ich wie gesagt ich halte da nicht so
viel von also bei uns zu Hause ist es so
wir haben einen Baum den wir geschmückt
haben aber der ist dann halt auch
richtig cool geschmückt und das ist halt
simpel und clean und das finde ich halt
schön bevor man sich da alle möglichen
chrisbaumkugeln an der dachin hängt das
mag ich eher nicht so also das ist
natürlich meine Meinung es kann sein
dass ihr sagt nee wir haben das zu Hause
so und wir finden das super schön ich
finde das schön zum angucken aber darin
zu wohnen finde ich nicht so toll und
ich denke wenn ich da jeden Tag Fahrad
herfahren müsste find ich das auch
irgendwie komisch wenn mich da mitten in
der Nacht so ein totales LED geplimper
anlächelt aber das ist natürlich jem
seine Sache und ich denke also meine
Meinung dazu ist einfach dass ich es
nicht so toll finde okay die Sonne geht
schon unter ich schreib mal kannst du
schlafen weil wenn ich jetzt das ach da
hinten steht da sogar gerade dann
schauen wir doch mal was der kedos da
hinten macht habe hier auch ein
Bettchen so komm mal mit kedos
kedoslein komm komm bei Dir ja komm bei
mir komm damit rein nchste Frage von
Subzone was machst was macht für dich
Weihnachten besonders Menschen die auf
dem Boden fliegen weil es rutschig ist
maybe das ist extrem witzig wirklich
wenn man auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt ist
mein toller Weg nach unten WD kaputt
gemacht irgendwie ist hier echt jemand
im Projekt der einfach Wandalismus
betreibt das ist echt das kann nicht
sein der Weg hier nach unten der muss
natürlich noch so ein bisschen
verschönert werden das muss ich
natürlich selbst zugeben der geht dann
halt hier um die Kurve ganz ehrlich
gesagt und dann werde ich wahrscheinlich
sogar gleich mich wieder in dieser Höhle
befinden ja schaut mal da fällt mal wie
wieder in die Höhle rein okay das geht
hier eins hier zwei zwei nee warte eins
so eins so nee da muss noch eins weiter
und noch eins runter und dann ist hier
diese
Plattform also ich finde an Weihnachten
besonders sind viele Dinge und zwar am
besondersten finde ich einfach an
Weihnachten was für mich Weihnachten
ausmacht ist einfach so wenn du von
draußen kommst es ist kalt z.B heute war
einkaufen mit ein paar
Uni
matrikulatination Typen ich weiß nicht
matrikulanten
ich weiß nicht genau wie das heißt
Studienkollegen und da war es richtig
kalt heute in Hamburg also es hat echt
auch ein bisschen geschneit jedenfalls
waren wir halt dann einkaufen in der
City und da war es richtig kalt und wir
haben dann auch ein Glühwein danach
getrunken und ich bin jetzt Hal wieder
zu Hause schön im Warmen und ich finde
das macht Weihnachten für einen für mich
aus dass man wirklich so man oh jetzt
kommen da so viel Keys auch noch runter
geplumst man kann wirklich so rausgehen
es ist kalt aber dann ist man zu Hause
und dann ist es so wieder warm ich weiß
nicht das finde ich halt ganz cool an
Weihnachten ich glaube ich bin schon ein
zu weit ne oder warte zwei stüfchen hier
ist wieder nur eine dann muss ich drei
hoch hoppeln ne ja genau dann geht das
hier wieder auf die Höhe also ich weiß
nicht das macht für mich Weihnachten aus
dass es draußen halt kalt ist und man
danach reingeht und es ist so schön warm
und alles das das finde ich halt ganz
cool und halt einfach so glühweinn und
sowas alles sopie B schreibt was war
bisher das Weihnachtsgeschenk über dass
du dich am meisten gefreut hast ich habe
mich eigentlich über Recht alle muss ich
sagen Weihnachtsgeschenke bisher gefreut
weil es einfach so vom Herzen kommt und
ich denke mal wenn mir jemand etwas
schenkt dann ist es schon ganz cool und
dann sollte man nicht so sagen oh das
ist aber nicht schön weil die Person hat
ja Gedanken darüber gemacht und hat es
einem geschenkt kostenlos und das finde
ich auch ganz cool aber das wo ich mich
am meisten drüber gefreut hat war dieser
tekronic Lego Kran damals mit dem man
auch so Wasser spritzen konnte ich weiß
nicht ob es den noch gibt im Handel
wahrscheinlich nicht aber den fand ich
echt am coolsten weil der auch so mit
Fernbedienung war und das war richtig
außergewöhnlich dass man da mit dieser
Lego Sache noch so
Sachen so rum mit mit Technik und so
weil das war damals echt so ein so ein
Weltneuheit dass man mit diesem dass man
mit Lego Technik verbunden wurde dass
ich das wirklich steuern konnte mein
Lego Auto letztendlich das war ganz cool
und ich glaube ich fange jetzt endlich
mal mit dem lu dann könnt ihr eigentlich
so mehrere lus machen dann mache ich
hier erstmal so ein kleines irgendwie da
muss ich natürlich gucken wie ich das
hinkriege mit dem mit dem Platz mit dem
mit dem ob ich das mit dem Kreis
hinkriege fünf nee das ist noch nicht
mein Haus 1 2 3 4 5 ah okay gut dann
denke ich werde ich hier dann einfach
mal so noch ein Stückchen höer gehen ich
brauche locker viel mehr Schnee ich muss
auf jeden Fall noch mal in das
schneebiom da hinten aber ich würde
sagen da wir schon wieder hier in meiner
Datei se ich egal wir sind bei 13 oder
12 Minuten schon wieder ich neh noch
eben die letzte Frage die fünfte für
heute
@ fashion Apfel #fe hast du auch einen
Adventskalender nee also ich hatte
überlegt mir einen zu kaufen aber ich
bin mir bei sowas immer nie so sicher
weil dann habe ich nachher hier
rumstehen und die Teile kosten ja schon
so 20 € und ich bin ein recht sparsamer
Dude und wenn ich dann so ein Ding für
20 € kaufe dann denke ich mir das S 20 €
h ich auch anders investieren können und
Schokolade esse ich eh nicht so gern ich
weiß schlachtet mich oder schlachtet
mich köpfig was laber ich das geht echt
schnell dass man das hier so kaputt Haut
na ja Pack da mal lieber Schnee hin
damit das hier schon so ein bisschen ach
guck mal das ist genau die gleiche
Textur wie Schnee mit diesem Gras das
ist ja cool ich weiß nicht ich habe
keinen Adventskalender damals hatte ich
einen vom FC Bayern München vier Jahre
lang hintereinander und von aminia
Bielfeld weil das meine
lieblingssportvereine sind aber da war
halt in jedem Kalender Dings buums dann
so ein eigenes eigene Figur drin immer
von dem Verein und so das war halt echt
ganz cool eigentlich aber dieses ja
irgendwie gar nicht weil ich weiß nicht
dann mach ich dieses kalenderding auf
und dann liegt da diese Schokolade und
dann esse ich die nachher eh nicht also
ich weiß nicht da bin ich echt nicht so
der Fan von ich muss mal schauen wie ich
das hier mit Fenstern mache ich glaube
ich mache das nämlich einfach so dass
ich
jetzt habe ich natürlich genau wieder
falsch gemacht ich packe hier immer so
an die Seiten hier packe ich ein Fenster
hin und hier pack ich muss wirklich nur
einmal mit der Maus da drauf drücken
wenn ich dann zweimal drücke dann ist
direkt wieder alles kaputt Fu meine
lieben Freunde aber ich würde sagen das
bauen wir wan anders fertig Glas müsste
ich auch noch brennen ne ich habe mir so
ein bisschen Sand geholt aber hab i noch
nicht hier reingepackt ach komm das
machen wir jetzt noch eben D ma ich
jetzt noch eben so ein bisschen hier ein
bisschen Kohle dann möchte man natürlich
das Ganze dann noch immer schaffen ich
muss mal schauen wie ich das dann noch
oben noch ausbaue das soll natürlich
auch nicht so hoch werden ich denke ich
mache das jetzt einfach dann so so ein
bisschen dann geht das hier vielleicht
hier so eine Kurve eine kleine Kurve
dann mache ich die hier auch in diese
kleine Kurve so dann ah hier musste der
Schnee hin ich Volltrottel und zack und
dann kann ich den Kollegen hier schon
mal wegnehmen den hier baue ich auch
schon mal ab dann setze ich hier einen
Schnee hin hier ist schon ein Schnee
hier muss dann auch noch ein Schnee hin
und der hier kommt auch weg ja hier oben
muss ich jetzt gucken was ich hier oben
mache ich glaube ich mache das einfach
so und dann kommt da oben irgendwie so
windabzug irgendwie wenn man das haben
die meisten los echt oben dass man oben
so ein kleinesck Loch hat bzw dass da
halt der Rauch raus kann wenn man innen
drin sich irgendwas brutschelt oder so
das perfekt ich habe schon mal sechs
Glas die reichen schon mal
sonst würde ich sagen meine lieben
Freunde wenn ihr a ich voll Idiot wenn
ihr irgendwelche Themen habt und ihr
denkt h das sind weihnachtliche Themen
die interessieren mich und die werden
eventuell ganz cool dass Luca die
zusammen mit dem oder dem Youtuber
zusammen beantwortet dann schreibt sie
einfach unter den hashag freeze auf
Twitter dann werde ich da drüber
berichten und da euch meine Meinung zu
kund geben und sonst würde ich sagen
meine lieben Freunde so sieht das eclue
aus ich habe dazu jetzt noch nicht na ja
noch nicht so viel mir Gedanken zuüber
macht ich denke so sieht's auch aus
vielleicht wird es echt cooler gewesen
wenn ich hier noch ein bisschen Schnee
hinlege das wer ich noch machen und das
da oben doch wegnehmen aber mal schauen
ich finde es geht fit sonst würde ich
sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat würde
ich mich über eine Bewertung freuen und
wir sehen uns dann morgen im nächsten
Part wieder bzw morgen im den Minecraft
facts tschüss